The price breaks through a level, a
sharp move, and volume spikes. Was it
just a large buyer stepping in, or did a
chain of stop orders get triggered one
after another? And what about that limit
order? Is it thin liquidity, or is there
hidden volume behind it? You can't tell
from a standard order book. But today,
we'll show you three new indicators
built for exactly this. A standard order
book shows only the total volume at each
price level, how many contracts there
are in total. MBO shows every order
inside that volume separately. Think of
it as a line at a store. A standard
order book tells you there are 12 people
in line. MBO shows you each person, when
they arrived, how long they stayed, when
they left, and who came next. This is
where everything else comes from,
icebergs, stops, sweeps, and hidden
manipulation by large market
participants. You follow individual
orders inside the order book. So, let's
start with the iceberg indicator. It
seems to be the one you've been waiting
for most. An iceberg is a limit order
that hides part of its real volume. The
visible portion gets taken, but the
order stays there, and there's hidden
liquidity underneath it. That's what the
first indicator tracks. You'll find
details for each order in three places,
the tooltip, the detail panel, and the
timeline window. There, you'll see the
total executed volume, executed, the
detected hidden volume, hidden, the
maximum visible portion of the order,
max, how long it was observed, the
confidence level, and the full history
of changes down to individual MBO events
and trades. There are three filters for
searching, [music]
min hidden volume, min total volume, and
min duration. They filter out the small
stuff, leaving only the larger
participants on the chart. Want to see
individual trades, too? Turn on show
individual trades. Want to highlight the
most important icebergs with labels? Use
show volume labels, label min volume,
and label mode. And when the market is
crowded and the labels start
overlapping, turn on cluster overlapping
labels. It groups nearby icebergs into
[music] clusters. Below the chart is
aggregated activity. It shows how bid
and ask icebergs behave over time. You
can configure it using bid, ask series,
delta line, and the aggregation modes.
There are five modes. Each one has a
different purpose. Exponential half-life
gradually reduces the influence of older
events. Newer events carry more weight.
Cumulative mode, also called total sum,
adds up statistics over the entire
observation period. Reset every interval
resets the accumulated values at set
intervals and starts again. Sliding
window looks only at activity from the
last n seconds. Same side sum
accumulates activity while one side
remains dominant and resets when the
dominant side changes. Next is
accumulation time. It controls the time
interval for resetting the histogram.
This is where you adjust the indicator
to match your trading style. Let's look
at an example.
We'll increase min hidden volume to five
contracts. We'll also increase min
duration to five seconds. We're looking
for those who are willing to wait. And
look at the result. These orders stayed
active for around 10 minutes. They sat
there and waited for the price to move
lower. They got what they were waiting
for. The orders were filled. Sometime
later, the price moved up out of this
range and a local reversal occurred. To
make sure you don't miss moments like
these, set up alerts. An alert is
triggered when an iceberg first reaches
[music] the specified executed volume.
You can also choose between different
display modes. You can show only the
upper panel with icebergs on [music] the
chart, only the aggregated statistics
below, or both at the same time. [music]
Ready for the next one?
A familiar situation. The price makes a
sharp move, but the move quickly fades,
and it was just someone's stop orders
getting triggered one after another.
That's a stop run. The stop tracker
looks for exactly these moments. After
the first impulse, a series of stop
orders starts firing, and MBO comes into
play again. The algorithm separates
normal market aggression from trades
triggered by stops. One important point,
this isn't only about stop loss orders.
Stop orders can be used either to exit a
position or to enter the market. The
indicator shows when stop-driven
aggression starts in the market.
Each stop run event is shown as a price
range. The sequence of triggers unfolded
within that range. Hover over the
highlighted area, and the tooltip shows
the details. Total volume, the number of
stop aggressors, the price range, the
event duration, and the initial impulse
that started it all.
At a glance, you can see the scale of
the move, how quickly it developed, and
the context. The main filters are min
volume,
max window,
min range,
and min stops count.
They determine which events appear on
the chart.
For more precise filtering, use max
stops count.
You can keep only large stop sequences
or only shorter ones. The appearance of
the highlighted areas is configured
through highlight style, highlight
[music] size, and highlight line
thickness. Buy and sell colors are
configured separately using buy stop run
color and sell stop run color.
You can turn pop-up information on or
off using show tooltips.
Below the chart, you'll see total buy
and sell stop run activity over time.
You can configure it using show buy
sell, show delta, and activity
accumulation. The accumulation modes are
the same as for icebergs. Once again,
accumulation time sets the time period
for the calculation. Let's look at an
example. The chart shows a downtrend,
and we're interested in two things.
First, where buyer stop loss orders were
triggered. These are targets for
sellers. Such moments often cause the
price to pause and correct. Second,
where seller stop loss orders were
triggered or where buyers became active.
These traders may have been trapped by
larger market participants. Let's adjust
min stops count. The smaller spikes
disappear, leaving only the main events.
Now, look at what we can see. On one
side, there are areas where stop runs
likely included buyer stop loss orders.
On the other side, and this is more
interesting, there are several spikes
that likely represent seller stop loss
orders. These often appeared near the
end of corrections. In other words,
these were good low-risk entry points in
the direction of the trend.
>> [music]
>> Now, let's return to alerts and display
modes. Using display mode, you can
choose what to show. Only the chart,
only the activity panel, or both at the
same time. Alerts are simpler here.
An alert is triggered as soon as a new
stop run passes your filters.
That leaves only the sweeps tracker.
Let's see what it can do. If stops are
about chains of stops getting [music]
taken out, then sweeps are different.
A sweep comes into play when one or more
aggressors remove liquidity in quick
succession across several price levels
in bulk.
The sweeps tracker catches these moments
and groups them into a directional
sweep. It answers one question. How
aggressively did the market move through
the order book? And what price range did
it cut through?
Each sweep is shown as the price range
crossed by aggressive order flow.
The filters are min volume, max window,
min range, min aggressors count, and max
aggressors count. They leave only the
significant moves through liquidity on
the chart. And separately, include
stops.
Turn it on, and stop volume is added to
the execution flow analysis. You can
immediately see how the volume is
divided between normal market aggression
and stops. This is useful because
sometimes an aggressive breakout
consists of 70% stop volume.
The appearance is configured through the
highlight settings by sweep color
[music] and sell sweep color. By
default, price level dots is selected.
It clearly shows the direction of the
sweep without overloading the chart.
Cluster labels by [music] X groups
labels from nearby sweep events, so the
chart doesn't become overloaded. Below
the chart, sweep event activity builds
up. It shows the balance between
aggressive buyers [music] and sellers.
The settings are familiar: show buy
sell, show delta, and activity
accumulation. Choose the accumulation
method using activity accumulation. The
modes are the same. Accumulation time
also sets the analysis horizon, and it
also determines how responsive the
indicator is to new events.
Let's adjust the settings [music] and
look for areas where aggression became
more intense. We'll lower min volume
from 100 to 45. We'll increase max
window from 100 to 1,000 milliseconds.
We'll raise min range from 1 to 5 to
find areas where aggressive order flow
moved through several price levels, and
we'll increase [music] min aggressors
count to 10.
Now, the market looks completely
different. During the downward move,
aggressive buyers stepped in right after
the decline stopped. For a while, they
managed to keep the correction going.
Then the price broke through their
activity zone, and bursts of seller
aggression followed. Now, you can draw
your own conclusions, right? These are
three tools that show what standard
market data doesn't reveal. Icebergs,
stops, [music]
and sweeps are now like an open book
right in front of you. Experiment with
the filters, track patterns, and try
these new tools in your own strategies.
See you on the platform.